oh we do the whole interview like that
yo mom yeah last one in Canada Toronto
mom Tijuana Mons so let's start to talk
about turn up Charlie March 15th
you are co-creator executive producer
and the star of the show that's a lot of
pressure it doesn't feel like you know
there's many questions to answer and
lots of things decisions to make but
also you kind of feel a little bit
closer to the project when you sort of
like a part of many strands of it it's
actually quite you know endearing it
feels like my baby yeah in the show
you're playing a struggling DJ but in
real life your little cello yeah which
is so cool yes very cool very I mean I
have struggled as a DJ at some points in
my life you know so I could relate to
Charlie at this point I've really found
the lane and Coachella man like wow it's
and of course it's crazy and I know you
played at Harry and Megan's wedding so I
did get into run at one time too did you
so no you you did it at the real wedding
but what is one song that gets people up
and dancing ah
you could go with Mike Jack record like
don't stop all blues away you could go
with a loofa Vandross record like see me
or never never too much yes you can go
over Earth Wind
I mean all that sort of funk error from
the 80s always gets people like you know
it doesn't matter whether you liked rap
or you're 10 you're gonna like those
songs so yeah so sexiest man alive
always brings a smile to my face I ain't
gonna lie oh really
what is their perks when you get this
kind of title and like at some point you
know are you gonna lose this title and
who are you who do you think you're
gonna lose the sexiest man alive alive
so as long as I'm alive I'm still the
sexiest oh right that's technically how
it works but no there were no perks you
would've thought they were pegs but the
only perk size that you get to be called
the title and it brings a smile relief
brings a big grin to my face sometimes I
sometimes Alex people do sorry what did
you say yeah say with chest deep voice
in there but now it's a privilege I mean
it's um it's uh Nona isn't it yeah to be
cold sexiest man alive just say oh god I
see you in the mirror no okay maybe a
little bit ma'am so what if you lost the
title to say like Dwayne who you're in
fast and furious possible Impossibles
question impossible no he's already been
sexiest man so so yeah oh well okay and
I know you're in that movie the trailer
looks really good so what was it like
taking him down or did you take him down
it remains to be seen
however it was a real epic journey
working with Dwayne and Jason and David
Leitch the director they you know that
that universe you know those guys have
been living in that universe I'm new to
that universe and I got to pull it I got
to bring some heat with a character that
we might not have seen in the franchise
and I was super excited to do it it's
great it was good work yeah yeah it's
hard work with good work hard work but
good work alrighty dress great show
thank you I love torn up Charlie it's
hilarious thank you you're funny in it
and congratulations thank you very much
good to see you again
you